Trump is going to start having trouble
with the base when it comes to vaccines
and I think he kinds of he kind of knows
it take a look but you have a lot of
people that love the vaccines I mean you
do they happen to be more Democrat than
they are Republicans can I ask the
question do you have a lot of people
there are people that say I saved 100
Million Lives I don't even talk about it
there are people who say
okay there are people who say uh you may
remember this one this is from about a
month ago Trump who doesn't seem to be
campaigning anymore right he's not he's
playing golf mostly these days and then
showing up a court every now and again
he was in Iowa I think about five or six
weeks ago and this was an interesting
moment because here is a constituent a
former Trump voter saying they're not
happy with him because of the vaccine
yeah well you know everybody wanted a
vaccine at that time and I was able to
do something that nobody else could have
done getting it done very very rapidly
but I never was for mandates I was I
thought the mandates were terrible
and
and you know there's a big portion of
the country that thinks that was a great
thing you understand that not a lot of
the people in this room but there's a
big but there is a big look I will give
credit where credit is due he was never
for mandates I never once heard Donald
Trump that you should get fired from
your job if you don't take it or the
federal government should do it or
anything else that's fully on the
administration 100 without question the
the second answer there though you know
there's a lot of people who like it like
that's kind of irrelevant was it the
right thing to do or not I know everyone
was Bamboozled by this again everyone
was in over their head and I can only
imagine what it would be like to be the
president of the United States all of
the experts who now we know we shouldn't
be trusting as much but all of the
experts coming in going you better shut
down the country you better do all of
this we better do blah blah blah or
everyone's gonna die and it's like
Trump's like you know I used to build
casinos like I guess I have to listen to
you guys so I don't blame him in a
certain sense for all that what I blame
him now for is how about just have a
nice Maya culpa just have a moment of
humility is that completely is there
literally nothing in you that would
allow for that and be like boy to my own
base I'm sorry that I did that or I
guess in retrospect it wasn't the best
thing or I do have some regrets but he
seems to be unable to show even the
slightest bit of Contrition and I think
that is a problem
foreign
[Music]